des oeuvres qui encagent d'autres la
médiathèque Jean rouselot de Guyancourt
accueille l'exposition d'art
contemporain let's stock painting elle
propose une scèneographie particulière
en six cabinets qui représente chacun un
peintre sur la devanture des façades
sont disposés les productions de
l'artiste derrière les créateurs
dévoilent d'autres travaux des textes
des dessins ou des symboles qui les ont
inspirés dans les laboration des
tableaux alors on peut regarder le
travail de route donc qui a un travail
qui utilise essentiellement des formes
géométriques des objets du réel on peut
voir une sorte d'arbre dans un dans un
vase une coupe avec des formes
géométriques assemblées et puis des
couleurs très vives qui appartiennent un
peu à l'univers enfantin et si on
regarde ce qu'elle nous a présenté au
Verseau du coup vous allez voir que on a
on a une toute petite image qui en fait
est un dessin qui appartenait à son papa
et quand on fait le parallèle entre son
est hétique et le dessin de son père on
retrouve ses couleurs vives et on
retrouve également l'idée par exemple de
l'arbre ou en tout cas des formes
géométriques et des couleurs vives
assemblées à la fin de la visite une
fiche de jeu est disponible pour les
plus jeunes autour des œuvres
l'exposition se déroule jusqu'au 19 mai